how can i better this team on the floor
off the floor in the locker room and
just be completely honest you know with
myself in those relationships around me
and
this was the most fun i've had this past
year it was so honestly you could tell
oh yeah
[Music]
oh kevin love is in the building man
it's been a long time coming
i never thought i would see the day okay
backstory for everyone kevin is a dear
friend of mine i have asked him to do
this show for what like going on two
years i would say yeah about two years
maybe even add some change to that but
here we are new york city yeah no better
place truly i mean it is the best city
it is i have to say you know one thing i
can always count on with you is you have
on air force ones i'm like have i ever
seen you not wearing air force well no
it's become like you know like karl
lagerfeld has this thing uh you know
always
had the same stuff on was beautiful but
for me it's just always been white air
force ones grew up in portland oregon
you know obviously phil knight bill
bowerman prefontaine the whole deal so
when air force ones came into my life i
was very young and i just went white
it's like a fast ball straight down the
middle can wear it up dress it up with
anything dress it down it's just it's
easy and it's a trademark it's a
trademark yeah it's become like my
uniform i feel like you know ball
players and and people within
our scope you started the sneakers right
totally yeah yeah no it's a staple she's
clean and white like it's good to go
yeah like it works for me and then it's
funny like the the you see like giannis
last year coming into game six or
whatever with like black forces on
everybody's like okay oh yeah
uh-oh yeah absolutely okay no i'm i'm a
big fan of them big fan of them and big
fan of you of course this is gonna be
likewise a super fun conversation um and
i actually want to start with instagram
because
you posted a picture with an amazing
caption that i thought was super
powerful and it encapsulated everything
that you went through this season um and
i would actually like you to read it out
loud okay okay who has the i've got it i
was appropriate and uh well i guess
respectful and didn't um bring my phone
in here oh maybe i should look at this
professional
okay and a little
um
i guess context uh backstory super small
but i just woke up
in the morning i was so happy for tyler
hero people that know me know i'm a huge
fan of him i even said that like i love
his swag i love that he just
at his age i didn't know who i was like
i wasn't comfortable in my own skin i
didn't just own
who kevin love is or who kevin is and he
does that and he plays and i love what
spo does and their team and
you know i know we'll get into more
playoffs and basketball type stuff but
i'm a huge fan of tyler hero knew he was
going to win the award but i thought man
if even if i'm i'm runner-up and i go
into you know this that same context
here
um that that was something to be proud
of after coming after like a injury 100
riddled season and just you know being
there for my teammates being a part of
the bigger picture in the organization
and being a part of something bigger
than myself so
i woke up you know whatever morning it
was less than a week ago and and
kind of was like all right i'm gonna
write a reflection of my 14th year yeah
so here we go
um tommy alter liked it
shout out to tommy by the way
uh so reflection year 14 after the most
frustrating injury of my career
in the 2020 2021 season and an exit from
usa basketball in the summer due to not
feeling fully healed and in shape many
people said i was done
some even went as far to say as quote
love should soon consider retirement end
quote this even came from some i thought
i respected to my face and behind my
back were fugazi loved the love the
if anybody knows me like the whole you
know donnie brasco you know anyways uh i
never let that commentary shake my
belief system i reevaluated a lot of
relationships but took the time to
assess the guy in the mirror first i
worked my ass off to come into the uh
excuse me the season healthy with the
goal of being available and the mindset
of helping lead a young
cavs team and taking the next step
be the vet i never had early in my
career help build a winning culture that
permeates no matter the lineup to the
dogs you know that old man loves you
love that part
i had to throw that in there for my guys
sacrifice gives back more than it costs
for this team to make the leap i had to
sacrifice and come off the bench for the
first time since my sophomore season in
the nba 13 years ago
i didn't fight it and i was hungry to
have a positive impact and produce like
i always have i'm thankful for jb's
transparency and trust you allowed me to
be the best version of myself and it'll
always be bigger than basketball with us
numbers don't lie
so i'm just going to throw a few in here
for bench players i led the league in
double doubles broke a franchise record
of three-point field goals off the bench
led the team with 187
point maid field goals and tied the
league uh tied as a lead leaguer leader
excuse me in charges taken
um
as for my goal of being available i led
the team in games played and outside of
uh games missed due to kovid played in
every single game
this post might seem like too much
vanity for some because i was only
the runner-up for six man of the year
but it meant something to me to earn my
respect back in a league in a game that
i've dedicated my life to
re-affirmations
never be defined by what other people
say you are almost all of the time you
don't see the view or perspective from
the floor of the arena a lot of seats in
the arena are filled with people who
have never ventured out onto the floor
they sho they throw shade at a safe
distance
so keep showing up remaining hungry
and [ __ ] what they think
i love it
sing it out loud
is it a different feeling
yeah no and i think that was a big part
of the reason that i felt compelled to
to share that um i think it was good for
both brain and body but you know there's
people out there that you know so much
of the commentary is now the content
right like there's people that do it
right you do it right there's former
players that really do it the right way
there's people who at the very least
will meet you halfway with respect right
and i feel like
no matter if you're
you know the the
you know security guard equipment
manager all the people behind the scenes
that make everything work and everything
go
all the way to the owner of an
organization like you have to meet
everybody halfway with respect and
you know a lot of ways i feel like that
wasn't happening with me but to to
everyone i wanted them to know that you
know you you can't always give a [ __ ]
what people think you're not gonna make
it you can almost never give a [ __ ]
no seriously it's like it's a life hack
and it's not it's not just something
that's that's given to you it's a it's
definitely a learned thing and and again
took me
longer than most and took me you know
working on myself like i said assessing
myself in the mirror it's you know a
never-ending process that's the beauty
of basketball but also in life you can
always get better yeah so that's kind of
where i was at i wanted to get it off my
chest and again i i always try and if i
can uh pay it forward but at the same
time like exposing that and i always say
nothing haunts us like the things we
don't say
i had to let it
absolutely yeah well there are some
parts of it i really want to dive into
okay and have you expand on a bit so
some even went as far as to say love
should soon consider retirement this
even came from some i thought i
respected into my to my face and behind
my back were fugazi i never let that
commentary shake my belief system yeah
what are you referring to right here i
mean usa basketball nobody's
you know everybody knows what happened
there um
you know i had been part of the thing
that really hurt me with that whole
situation is
yeah sure i wasn't over my injury maybe
um you know there was not maybe there
was a couple
people that i i genuinely love and have
a great relationship with they're like
all right you should you know go to usa
basketball and show that you're healthy
and show that you're right so i'm like
yeah you're right i should and
you know in that i i totally owned up to
that and that's why i ended up you know
taking a step back assessing and being
like all right let's let these guys
meaning jerry colangelo and pop and sean
ford those guys let's have
take a step back
and say okay i've been a part of usa
basketball since i was 17 years old
and they can go get somebody that's
going to help them i am not
i was not able to be in the best shape
that i could have been because i
couldn't fully
run yet with my calf i couldn't fully
press off like i still could you know
really shoot the ball i could space the
floor i could rebound the basketball but
as far as switching one through five and
how they wanted to play it just wasn't
appropriate for me yeah and
you know in a different setting or
context or anything like that maybe it
might have worked out but i wasn't right
so i took a step back
reassessed the situation and said all
right if sometimes if things aren't
adding up you have to start subtracting
and sometimes it has to be yourself and
for me that was it
um
but then
you know people that i've had
relationships with throughout usa
basketball for that long threw me under
the bus and i didn't like that because
i felt that that i did the right thing
by coming to the
the landing spot and landing point that
i eventually got to there
and i just thought it was really unfair
and from this very elite fraternity that
we have in our 450 players
you know times that by
what would it be 45 or 12 players a
little bit less than that like
you know
the 10 guys or the 12 guys on the team
and then all that have come before
in usa basketball it's not many people
right so like that's even more elite
fraternity and you would think like you
you take care of each other 100 and like
i still love everybody there like sean
ford is a near and dear friend of mine
like he'll always will be and you know
grant hill is now taking it over he's
incredible um so i hope i'm a part of
that family from from here on out but
that was
you know the people that i was talking
to as well as media members that you
know were either
you know be some beat writers for us and
around you know they kept asking about
my body through the season i'm like no
no no even if i have to speak it into
existence of course i still feel like i
can be that same player totally and i
said when i went to usa basketball go
you know maybe i might have to take on a
new role in my career but
who knows i'm not gonna you know you
want to make god laugh tell me plans
right like i don't know i can't see into
the future will i get back healthy
absolutely but let's start there first
yeah but
again i think about it like you know the
four agreements like
be impeccable with your words
always do your best always do your best
assumptions and don't take anything
personal
so
it didn't take me long to to get over
that was it fuel and motivation um from
the commentary sure but again like i
said it never
shook my belief system and never
um
you know
messed with my love of the game and
where i thought i could be and how i
could help a young team like i i
definitely had to reassess and
had lengthy conversations with jb and
our families go back to the 70s and you
know jb has known about me since i was a
uh you know a little
a little i mean [ __ ] kid some times
no but no i mean like the bigger sets
they they mean a lot
to me and i genuinely love them even
just outside of
basketball yeah and you know
he was a big part of i mean that
continued conversation and and you know
continuity with what we were doing and
overall transparency like i said there a
lot of that was
was jb and him believing in me and being
with me my first three years in the
league and really being the first guy to
believe in me and said okay this kid
could be good yeah i mean and so when
you talk about usa basketball i know you
had the opportunity to address jerry
colangelo we saw that on the shop and
all those things what was the aftermath
of that did he reach out did he
apologize nothing um but
sean ford uh he reached out
um you know he's always been gracious i
love sean
he's been amazing to me and and to my
family
um for
you know i want to say almost 20 years
now but yeah dating back to when i was
you know 17 so a little you know 15 or
16 years and
um
you know pop we saw each other in san
antonio we intercepted each other he was
literally right outside our locker room
we had a had a great conversation um
and then grant hill called me as well
good um so these are people that you
know i i love and respect and again were
had met me uh halfway and
you know i i appreciate that i respect
that and you know i
it's not just that oh it's just it's
just a game it's just basketball but
again it's that elite fraternity like
you take care of the next man you pay it
forward you leave it in a better place
for the next generation and like we you
know you've been here interviewing all
of them like the next jen is so i'm so
excited so good yeah yeah it's so
exciting there's obviously
you know two or three years uh you know
before and after when i came into the
league um you know i have those guys as
peers but the the league is in
you know a really good place right now
so i think like again you have to you
have to do right by those guys but
that's
not that doesn't just stop at the
players and the coaches right that goes
to front office that goes to ownership
so like if you
i don't know i always feel like you get
what you give and i felt like i'd given
a lot to both usa basketball into the
game and um
you know it was just a an ugly spot for
me but again um like candace said
kenneth parker love what she said about
just you have to sometimes you have to
let time tell your story yeah and that
was one of the best
i was ready to run through a wall yeah
that was one of the best ever it's funny
that you talk about candace because when
she came on the show we had yet another
conversation about usa basketball and
i've had conversations with other nba
players about usa basketball and there
seems to be
a couple issues that bubble with how it
works how it's run and all these things
so what would you change
about usa basketball well that's funny i
never it's funny that i should say
because
grant hill and i never got the con
the the time to really get into it
because he called me and he just wanted
to i think pick different players brains
about
that exact thing how can we get better
how can we change moving forward you
know what do guys want this to look like
what do you you know feel about the
young guys how do you like how we play
you know those sorts of conversations
and and just the culture around usa
basketball as well i think
um because of you know it was tough
because when pop took over it was you
know guys dropping off or they were in
contract years or they didn't really put
together you know a dream team type
scenario and then covet happened and you
know it just there were so many
different factors that um
it just had a weird
feel to it yeah but thankfully you know
as as an american usa ended up winning
which is which is great was scary there
for a few moments oh yeah it was shaky
yeah it was shaky but but they got it
done and you know like they said
afterwards like what can they say now
like usa is still on top but again the
world is
the world is catching up no absolutely
which is exciting and fun it's like oh
it's very we're on top yeah but also
like you know and this is you know uh
going off of that it's like a few years
ago i remember like luca was
rookie of the year slovenia um giannis
obviously mvp from greece and then you
have ciaco from cameroon like what other
league can say that totally and that's i
was like this is so amazing it makes it
david stern's dream david stern's stream
i'm 100 and so foresight there watching
uh um winning time and like seeing him
like you know go to magic and burn
everything like just having the
foresight to see all that brilliant i
love that okay another part of the
caption i want to dive into you said but
took the time to assess the guy in the
mirror first
so what thing were you doing
that contributed to a difficult moment
in your career i think more so it was
you know you can't i put in i always put
in the work i've always chased the game
i understand that nothing happens
without that ball
um and again when i talk about earning
my respect back in a league that i've in
a game that i've dedicated my life to
right so
um
it was it was
like going to therapy i had to i always
said it like if you know the things
weren't adding up like something's going
on it's time to do the work so
you know i i gave a real look at myself
and it was one of the things i talked
about this year like i was i talked to
draymond about going from
you know
four straight finals expect expectations
uh to not only you know go to the finals
but win yeah nba championship
to then going to a team that's a
complete rebuild and you know you don't
fully understand what you're getting
yourself into and you you say you do and
you think you have this great
perspective and then you just lose
and that's really hard so when clay and
steph were out draymond had to go
through that too so we were
throwing a couple things off each other
it's not easy to do and i thought to
myself like what am i really upset about
here we have a great young nucleus
um you know the tr the trading of jared
allen was a was incredible we drafted
concepts and i know he he got hurt but
then
we didn't say oh we're gonna have this
small back court we can't then go draft
darius garland fifth we did
and we drafted evan mobley yeah uh
it's just you know the the the young
core the young nucleus sign laurie
market and karis levert like i could go
through our entire lineup it's
we're
made up to be good for a really long
time but from a leadership perspective
i'm like okay
and i mentioned it there like i never
had like a true true veteran that you
know i had to fight every day in
practice the closest thing probably
would have been al jefferson but he had
acl
terror yeah early
when i got there so i had to
learn a lot of things on my own i got to
cleveland with with likely some some bad
habits you know everything had kind of
run through me i didn't understand what
true sacrifice meant for
again something bigger than myself
but i thought okay i can apply that to
this situation as well it's not only
coming off the bench it's like
being there for dg like he's that's like
my little brother yeah you know finding
ways to to reach out and connect to
um getting evan to speak getting him to
speak and and and to have a breakthrough
season and say hey listen this could be
a lot of responsibility for you yeah
you're like you're like the one yeah if
you and dg and jay like that big three
like you guys are it yeah and then we
already did very well by the way and we
all built around you and we went against
the grain too i thought that was so
amazing with lowry too like that that
seven foot
lineup
you know three seven footers out there
um and then dg and ice i mean we have
again i meant i forgot to even say ice
like you think about that fifth pick and
you know had a really good year so
um
i think it was more than anything
assessing myself and saying okay
you know why was i upset
who am i really upset at
you know in a lot of ways i i looked at
in the mirror i'm like i'm upset with
you and like in some cases how you've
acted
and you know you've been hurt you can't
really control that but
you know how can i better this team on
the floor off the floor in the locker
room and just be completely honest you
know with myself in those relationships
around me
and
this was the most fun i've had this past
year was so
honestly honestly you could tell oh yeah
yeah the whole team but we were like it
was like every game was
you know the whole crowd is into it and
let me tell you cleveland fans you know
like if if you show up and you play hard
they're going to play
yeah they're there they're there and
they're gonna show up so when they
started we started to win games we
started to see more and more people feel
filled the arena rocket mortgage and i
think you know that created a culture
around us that we just we love being
together we pay it forward we're the
most pay it forward team share the
wealth and we celebrate each other like
i can remember
um
phoenix i was watching it was like an
interview with monty and
um
cp and devin and they were talking about
like celebrating the small wins within
the season
and i actually um you know had a
conversation um
with the coach of the year
congratulations in uh in miami and i'd
spoken about that i said man you know
what's so cool and i learned from you
guys and it's cool to learn new things
in your 14th year i said you guys
celebrate the little wins
within the season so it's not so
monotonous everybody's then you know
they're lifting after games
they're like so together it's like we i
looked at the miami heat i looked at
them i looked at
us and how we could apply all of that
and i i feel like we developed a real
really old excuse me a real culture that
people would gravitate towards like when
charis got to the team he's like
oh this is this is like a great and
we're like yeah like everybody jb gives
we make fun of him because he gives the
same uh
uh speech every time to a new player but
he's like no we really love each other
here we celebrate each other you know we
have complete freedom there's no fear
here and once you get past the fear
there's freedom in that like just just
go out there do the right thing you know
stick to our plan but then
outside of that you can grow within you
know the team everybody thinks of player
development is like i have to get better
for me but it's like how can you fit in
the scope like the player development in
how can we become a championship level
team right i think everybody understood
that on our team absolutely i mean so
you obviously you're incredibly
self-aware i think that you have a very
good gauge of what your ability is and
all of those things and you have a 42 to
stay like on the right track but you're
hearing all these things at this time
did you ever have a moment that you were
like
should i retire
no
okay no that i mean like hard no it's
like hard pass i was there was never
a moment
and i think
in some ways you have to like have a
feeling of i don't know if audacity is
the right word but you have to
um
again it's that core belief system and
and knowing again who you are listen i'm
incredibly flawed in a work in progress
i think you know some people that are
less you know there's there's levels to
it but for me i just i thought to myself
this this isn't it for me yeah i i know
in this league that
if you're healthy if you can shoot if
you can rebound you know that's that's a
luxury especially being a big so i've
always been able to do that that's not
gonna leave me
um those things i feel like i've put in
work to where it's second nature so um
you know i was able to
help the team and execute in a really
really
great way in 22 and a half minutes a
night like you know i wish i could would
play more minutes but like again we have
those seven footers that are out there
doing work and had us in the you know
top five in
pretty much every defensive category
across the board so uh again that that
sacrifice like i said gives back more
than it costs and i think we were either
plus 22 or 23 wins in the win column so
and had those guys not gotten hurt when
it might have been a 50-win season yeah
so um
and that all just lands back in the in
the same place of just
self belief and and not being defined by
you know what they
say you are so i guess you know in a lot
of ways thinking that you know the
deadlines on dreams is you know there's
no you know dreams don't have deadlines
they don't like it
i think it added new life and and
excitement
not only to
our organization but um you know
selfishly my me as well and those young
guys they call me old man and grandpa
i'm like how the hell
i'm like how is doe how was you know
rondo how is he not the oldest yeah he's
not grandpa
it's the gray hair that that gets
everybody so it's the big one i'm in a
steamed 33 years old
all right last thing from the caption
because i just love it so much um you
talk about gaining respect back
but did it hurt to feel like you had
lost the respect oh yeah
no as a as a as a human being and i i
know i'm talking to the man in the
mirror but
also like
coaching staff
kobe altman front office um
i think
my therapist like those are
conversations that i had i like had to
you know
let that out but i had spoken to doug
collins
actually at usa basketball and we had
talked about that he had actually come
to me and said
you know this is how you get your
respect back and this is how um you know
you you
solidify your integrity back in the game
and you you get that back
i mean he told me a great michael jordan
story it's one he's told before where
you know he had that string of however
many double
digit games in a row was 800 900 and
something i forget the number but
um
[Music]
he landed on eight points or whatever
and
jordan met him on the bus um
he's on the wizards and you know first
seat or second seat or whatever and said
hey coach you don't still think i can
play he's like yeah michael what are you
talking about he goes okay
you know he said tomorrow just you know
give me the ball
and so
you know they're staying at whatever
hotel that they were staying at i
believe in in georgetown and you know
doug's walking out early in the morning
and he sees michael down there you know
just putting this crazy lift and crazy
work drenched in sweat working with tim
grover and he's like man we're back to
back we got in 3 a.m in the morning and
jordan is down there
just chasing it working just working so
he goes out that night and scores 50
points and he's like yeah i told you
yeah i could still play yeah i could
still play
so that um
you know i
again
there i don't know if i had the the the
bandwidth at the time because i was
so in my head about my my injury and not
being able to to feel and
you know be myself out there on the
floor but it still hit home and that was
something that
i wanted
was to
get that feeling back of respect within
the league
and it first started with my teammates
more than anything and i had a moment
last year that was taken completely out
of context but that's neither here nor
there
in toronto that you know people still
brought up and it's funny because my
teammates go man that that was so like
just from looking at it from a
perspective i didn't unders see it until
after the game and i'm like oh god this
is going to be really bad yeah so
explain why you say it's taken out of
context um just because of like how it
how things are perceived or how they
look like yeah you go making assumptions
right
but i know how it looked um
and it was funny because i was actually
the reason it happened i was really
angry at courtney kirkland for i just
kept getting pushed into the back if you
see me i like go to the stanchion i'm
like trying to rip out like i was just
having an out-of-body experience
and i'm like courtney like
i forget who it was like just keeps like
pushing me in the back it should be over
the back call every single time wasn't
calling it we had lost three players the
night before in um
washington to
i've never seen this before concussions
and larry nance i think breaks his hand
or finger
and so we're we have you know eight
players or whatever it is and we're like
dying for a win we're struggling um guys
are banged up it's towards the end of
the season
um you know and so i smack the ball not
even knowing thinking i'm just gonna go
grab it and then inbound it goes in and
then they of course
of course they um i forget who it was
but ends up um you know hitting a three
and i'm just like oh god jb calls a
timeout i'm like just please berate me
and just go at me
but we go to the locker room after the
game and you know it's funny dg he's
like we good now so i
you know i apologize i'm like you guys
know that's that's not what it looked
like but that's on me
you know i'm supposed to be your vet i'm
supposed to be your leader but i think i
took that frustration out there and had
nothing to to do with them but again
that's that was the context of it like i
talked to even dean wade on our team he
was like laughing he's like that was
such like a
a non-thing that people made it out to
be something that it wasn't but as it
goes i know it i know what it looked
like and absolutely i would have
probably thought the same thing because
you know a narrative takes on a life of
its own and that's just what it is but
um
no i i think it was built out from my
teammates first and in getting that
respect back um
and
you know so much of relationships is
communication but also half the battle
or maybe more is showing up and that's
what i wanted to do for them for sure i
mean i've had conversations with jamal
crawford about this the williams about
this about the best
um
about
kind of the adjustment
that comes with saying okay hey i'm the
sixth man yeah
what role did ego play
in that adjustment for you if any i mean
i have an ego there's no no doubt like i
remember coach k in usa basketball he's
like no no i want you guys you guys all
have egos and you're here for a reason
like you didn't get here
you know it's like what was the quote in
uh uh billions is like you don't you
don't become a billionaire pitching
underhand it's like we didn't get to
this point by not having that yeah uh
but he goes i want you to all bring your
egos here for the you know
the greater good of of
this room everybody in here so
um
i just thought i could thrive in that
role i really believed it and jb
um i was like listen i have no problem
earning my minutes i have no problem
going out there and fighting i think
that'll give me extra
motivation and i know that i know that
my teammates love me and my teammates
know that i love them so what you know
put me out there for 20 to 25 minutes a
night i can get a lot done so i've
always prided myself on on being
productive
um efficient
you know obviously games go like this
more often than not you're working your
way towards a
you know healthy progress
and i just honestly i felt like i could
do a lot in that six-man role i really
did and and you did yeah and ego ego
definitely uh played a part in it but
again i didn't fight it i didn't fight
it at all yeah i i think that's like
surprising to me though that you didn't
fight it at all
because it's me okay
because it's anyone you know like it's
anyone that is having to
majorly adjust what they're used to
in some ways what you think in your head
is a backseat you know to what you're
used to
you know i i think it's going to be when
it's all said and done you're going to
say kevin love took a backseat to evan
mobley
[Laughter]
he is yeah i'm i was i i saw him and i'm
like oh wow i get it wow yeah he's he's
obviously bias i thought he should have
won rookie of the year i know it was a
very close battle scotty scottie barnes
a beast kind of kate cunningham awesome
player continued to get better
throughout the season but i just i love
his makeup um evan's makeup i love his
brain and and how he
um
lets everything come to him quiet quiet
guy but like 20 years old why i
interviewed him at the draft oh no so
quiet you got to get him really nice but
so quiet yeah so quiet so like he's
already that great great defensively and
yet he just he doesn't like have the
communication skills yet i mean he has
the skills i just think we need to get
him to talk yeah but isaac accord was
the same way
it was like the first year he's like man
and he's like people ask me who do i
think like
loki the funniest guy on the team like
ice is so funny
he is so funny uh and i don't think
people enough people know that about him
but i'm hoping that
because he started now we can't get him
to shut up
ice yeah so like i'm hoping it's uh it
won't be the same thing with with evan i
know but
um no i get excited about where his game
could go because eventually he's gonna
step out and and you know shoot more
threes
um you know he's gonna have that kg type
of post game and then you know between
him and j.a like those are going to be
all defensive players yeah at that
position yeah okay so you mentioned
awards you're talking about mmobilly
evan mobley rookie of the year um and i
really want to get your perspective on
this draymond is someone i talk to about
awards all the time sometimes you agree
sometimes you disagree i have a vote i
actually voted evan won i voted scotty
too i voted k3 but congrats to scotty he
was very very deserving
with awards
what can we do to get at least some
group of players a vote i fully agree
yes that's where i i think draymond
really hit it on the head to uh talking
about like the years and if i didn't
like a certain guy and how i can vote
like
and then
i think i love watching jordan pool by
the way yeah and the fact that he wasn't
and and how far he progressed during the
season
um because i agree like
could josh is ja worry worthy of the
award i mean he's like worthy of of mp
mvp consideration like of course he
could you know like the most improved
player i think he was already great
yeah you know he was already you know
solidified but no happy not mad at him
winning it i think i've i've said since
he almost jumped over me and dunked on
me that i was like okay this guy's going
to be special
um
but no i think i think draymond's right
i i do believe that you know
in some cases i don't know
you know a selection of your peers
should be able to have some say on who
they believe agree at least ends up
in like the finalists yeah right because
the fact that
jordan poole went in there is i mean so
that's what i said to jim and i i said
the discourse about this should be how
is jordan pull not even in the final
three because what that indicates is
some people just didn't even vote for
him like you can argue about who wins an
award all day right but the finalist
yeah he's not a finalist he's not a
finalist i i didn't i didn't understand
that yeah okay but this is my only thing
about most improved i will say and i had
jordan in my and my votes but
somewhere along the way
people started to think the award is
like
most unlikely to improve and that's not
the award it's not the award like the
award is it is funny yeah you understand
what i'm saying yeah of course like it's
truly just about improvement so i get
the argument for both sides
but we're kind of changing what the
award means like people are like i get
it you want like a fringe player to get
it you want somebody to get that love
and that's important but if we're just
talking about improvement yeah that does
apply to some guys hey look at jaws
numbers yeah made a major jump yeah it's
like we're just arguing degrees of
improvement correct you know and like i
don't know if it's necessarily talent
levels because i think uh you know pool
is a extremely talented player i mean
look what he's done even in the playoffs
in his first go around right like
um
but yeah being someone who who won
that award in 2011 i didn't really start
shooting threes until my third year so
like that there was that improvement
yeah you know i had i had took in a big
jump in numbers i think for i went from
like 14 and i know average a double
double in my second year but to like 20
points and then from 11 rebounds or 12
rebound whatever it was to 15.
like that those are
big jumps that absolutely you know i
think um in some cases were
unexpected but i i certainly improved
on a number of levels but i yeah it's
most improvement is a weird thing
it's probably this interpretation yeah a
firm interpretation like obscure
award and by obscure i mean like it's
it's definitely
you know something that you can't
put in a box and say okay this is how
it's defined right a lot of gray area
with most improved and we're seeing a
lot of great work what draymond was like
alluding to right and i i loved his take
on that i think the thing that's getting
people kind of caught up with jaw is
it's that he won rookie of the year
but
great
players have won most improvements yeah
but it's just we forget because i mean
paul george paul is one most improved
player
yeah like people have won most improved
player that you're like he's perennial
all-stars yeah this type of player but
it's that i love award season because
everybody debates um okay wait how do
you define mvp
are you like okay it's the person you
just
like i i feel like it's like when
jordan every year or like lebron through
the 2010s like you could give it to him
every single year yeah i mean outside of
steph uh maybe a few years but those
guys like one and two to one a one b
like all the time right across the board
but it's just so hard to
i know that
joker got knocked they got knocked out
in the first round but
what he did
this season was unprecedented numbers
and it's a regular season award
you know what i mean like yeah so it's
like okay you got bounced out yeah we
submit the votes before that you know
what i mean
but that is one i would have been happy
if embiid won i think he deserved it me
too jokic won he deserved it it's just
it just kind of comes down to but
the pressure that is on the media i'm
like is this a thing that the media
solely
should decide there has to be another
voice yeah how do you fix it okay but i
think if it was judged on by again peers
or players and that fraternity that i
talked about i still feel
that if you
you know it's like the curve on the test
if you weighted
the
media
and
i still think that jokic
uh
he
ends up on top i really do yeah
um and and b not far behind i mean
giannis again could be every single year
um and there's a number of players after
that that i don't think are in that top
finalist group but um i think yeah all
three are well deserving and but i do
think that there's
something to be said for
you know
players especially that that give
themselves to the game really know the
game
um take the time to know the game which
isn't everybody but totally and you know
because some people like draymond even
says like you don't know what you're
looking at yeah and that's totally fair
um
that there has to be something there i
don't have the answer um so i can say i
don't know but i i do think that there
is some other way that we can pivot and
and make it so
others are involved and it makes sense
there is something there yeah i do like
this idea though of having this maybe
player committee that adds a vote to the
finalists i'm into that yeah yeah we're
ready
to start that campaign well if they can
all come to
[Music]
um
you know it can't be like a jury trial
where it's like one person you know like
can't be like that but if they all
um
you know withdraw the straws and you
know and they all
end up with you know that per that's the
vote that they get the accumulation of
that guy getting the top score in the
votes or whatever it may be but there's
something there with
um some sort of player committee that
should make sense yeah okay so you
mentioned lebron you're talking about
people that could always been mvp yeah i
am
fascinated uh by you and lebron's
friendship and the reason is
it is kind of rare for people to stop
playing together and still be close yeah
that is not a thing that usually happens
why do you think you all are still close
yeah i think um
braun and myself and his whole crew we
just like we
we became family whether it be you know
randy or
rich
um
have like everybody within his world um
i've been very fortunate to to become
close to and a part of their story um as
well as bronze and
we've continued that friendship like i
saw him last week at the f1 race in
miami and it was just again never never
a dull moment never
we always leave off and and feel like
when we get back together it's the same
page and it's just so much love there
and i think you know us keeping in touch
through a group chat where it's
uh six of us on it from our 2016 team
yeah and you all are in it every day
every single day i mean it's constant
and we talk about everything i think
that's the beauty of it um it's
definitely a safe space guys throw out
different things if guys are going
through a moment
we're very supportive
and again like if somebody needs to
get get clowned or trashed or put you
know ran through the mud we do that as
well like it's all it's all good at the
end of the day but i think um
you know
braun first was somebody that that was
you know i was looking up to somebody i
wanted to compete against somebody that
i thought i could uh you know play with
um
and then we
took on a very unique you know
friendship in that way where it's become
a brotherhood and something that'll be
you know lasting for i think as long as
we live yeah i mean trust me i get it i
know group chats are sacred but yeah
last time you were clowned in the group
chat
oh probably when braun dunked on me
yeah i mean that that was like a severe
clown and i just you know some things
you're like you get out ahead of right
but i was like all right guys let's hear
it
that's that was your first text when you
got to the oh yeah i was like all right
let's hear it all right come on like
let's [ __ ] hear it i'm ready i'm
ready just go for it because this is
good you know because most
like story lines and everything there's
there's it's become just so much because
you know you have to have material and
and so much content nowadays it's like a
two-week window yeah lifespan and so
like that'll be on a career highlight
for him especially with the lakers yeah
yeah it's like yeah i hate it had to be
him right like that's what he says like
man just get out of the way
um but
you know first of all it happens to
everybody but uh that was definitely a
moment the last moment that i got
clowned on that group chat at the very
least yeah i mean but you get it like i
really yeah that was a lot because you
know i think richard was like oh my god
i was like oh [ __ ] here we go yeah here
it comes and channing just you know he
he wants to throw
you know rocket fuel onto the fire like
it's not enough to just like spray a
little bit he's like
so of course i love that like just the
the 2016 champs group chat yeah does it
have a title
uh
it changes every now like we changed the
photo the other day because i think that
um
richard changed it to something i forget
uh
anyways channing was it may be a little
bit too explicit for this but channing
was eating it
he was eating a churro
and i screenshotted it it didn't look
right
and so i sent it to the group chat
everybody's like okay so richard
immediately took it rich immediately
took it and just put it as the photo and
then channing changed it and like it
just
and it's just little stuff like that
yeah well you had to be there but
everybody does it within their chat and
gets you know
it's it's just again a safe space we let
anything so funny yeah what i always
think about i interviewed chris paul
they'd be like
two years ago
and you're talking about lebron and he
says taylor lebron is the most frugal
person i know he says when we walk into
a place the first thing lebron says is
what's the wi-fi password i don't want
to use my data oh yeah yeah oh yeah i've
seen it a million times in toronto
and like
you know
they talk about like wealth and all that
like sometimes it's the things you don't
see
and for him it's like you know behind
the scenes he he
we're in toronto right like that drive
from
the airport and going through customs to
then getting to our hotel yeah there's
no
there's no data used at all like he's
waiting for the wi-fi all the time and
then so that then that drive from the
hotel to then the arena
air canada
also waits for to get to the arena wi-fi
like that's so funny you know like
what's uh
finance great saying uh a small leak can
sink a great ship but like that's like
that's
yeah i gotta say it's not like i'm out
of there but i'm like come on bro like
seriously yeah just get get on wi-fi you
want it like
maybe it's good for you to get away from
your phone for a minute but like
i don't know it's it's just
you know roaming i don't know um are you
having a bachelor party and is it going
to be like 2016 champs at the party no
no so i wanted nothing to do with a
bachelor party um really i want nothing
because what do you know what what do
i don't want to wake up every morning
feeling terrible and like sure
um
i don't know if i just didn't think it
was my thing but my best friend and i
from back home
speaking of one um his dad collected
cars race cars
uh
my best friend ernie was a he was
actually a national champion um
uh go-kart racer at one point he stopped
he stopped racing which
uh it was too bad especially with uh
where the sport's gone now but his his
dad
uh who's like a father figure to me had
gone to the monaco grand prix like a
number of times
right so
we had talked about it maybe for 15 20
years now like oh we got to go and we
get the chance we got to go and we get
the chance so like after
you know last year's fireworks and
controversy and everything that happened
in f1 right with with um
you know those two drivers um
you know it was i was like okay this
might be the year that we're going so
he's like i'm not having a bachelor
party he's getting married in
in august and so i'm like all right
we're gonna go to the monaco grand prix
so long as we're not in the playoffs so
we can book it up you know if we're not
and then
you know
liverpool is now playing
you know in the champions league final
on that saturday night
you know wine country is right there and
on top of that i've always been a huge
um not only rafa fan but a major major
federer fan growing up as well so we get
to see the semi-finals of the french
open so it's like we get to hit all of
these different things and so it's more
i like experiences i like experience
driven things things that are super
memorable other than you know i don't
want to drink till i don't remember
right you know what i mean yeah i i
sometimes i like to you know if i
mess up in a game or something i like to
drink until it feels like i did the
right thing but i'm never gonna get to
the point where like you know i'm i'm
in a bad
i don't want to get to a point where i'm
in a bad spot and like oh guys i can't
do this another night yeah well it's
funny you say so i will say one thing
about being friends with kevin you will
always eat well and you'll drink well
you always pick good wine and i'm like
not a wine person but i feel like i'm
always drinking the wine i'm supposed to
be drinking so kudos you're hanging with
the right crowds though yeah absolutely
okay this is like totally unrelated um
but when i was researching for this
interview i watched like a bunch of your
interviews and you said something in an
interview with graham bensinker i
believe
and you're talking about minnesota and
your time there
and you said
a lot of went on there for a few years
wasn't normal and i still haven't seen
today and i probably never will yeah
what are you referring to
so i i guess i would have to know
context but um in terms of mine you said
it when he asked about the contract
being shown to you oh but then you were
saying there was a litany of things that
were not normal right there was a lot of
things going on um
and i believe maybe some of them still
are with with that organization i i
really did enjoy my time there people
say oh you know minneapolis i'm like
minneapolis was amazing and it still is
like it's
probably one of the most underrated
cities within the league and
professional sports i mean
in the vikings you have the twins uh you
know xl energy center you have the wild
um you know target center obviously you
have the timberwolves like in lynx like
you have
you know these
really
um
maybe famous is a is a strong word but
like very notable
sports teams
um like i grew up loving kirby puckett
like i also like minnesota i was like
this is so cool i want to go to
minnesota one day kg came along that was
one of the first games outside of
portland that i had ever seen a
professional game and kg and dirk and
tim duncan were all you know some of my
favorite power forwards of all time
during that era so
um no i think just a lot went on there
behind the scenes that was
you know that i still haven't seen to
this day like jb and i even talk about
it it's like
you know
you think you've seen it all
and
then just more and more happens but
what's like in your head when you're
saying that like what are you referring
to well
this is what and some might some some
people might feel a certain way about
this and i'm
i'm thankful for advanced statistics but
sometimes they don't always um
tell the force full story but in a lot
of cases like i said they don't lie
and what really pained me was you know
in my
six years we never made it to the
playoffs
but we also had a revolving door
with coaches
and with players and like no continuity
not spending to get free agents
um
no real like linear path or idea of what
this is going to look like
and
again we
we had a
chance to
draft steph like can you imagine steph
and and ricky rubio and i love johnny
flynn i really do but i played against
uh steph in college like he had us down
20. thankfully we came back and won the
game we had you know russ guarding him
but he still
he i was like man this who is this
little baby face
assassin
um but no saw him firsthand uh you know
i didn't think that obviously
hindsight's always
20 20 at least in your mind but i just
felt like there
were a number of things that that went
wrong there um
and and again like i had to look
in the mirror at myself as well like my
mental health a couple
a couple of those years was
in a in a really awful place um
but i i think it was probably an
accumulation of
just
um
chaos but you know some people thrive in
that and some people don't and i feel
like i certainly um did not but i was
happy to see their successes here like
edwards i could watch him sit here and
do anything he's so fun yeah he's so fun
and again like a guy that just
it's like okay he doesn't fully
understand like who he is yet or like he
has a self-belief system and like
knowing how great he can be
but
he is just so comfortable in who he is
he's funny he can talk like he he's you
know in the new adam sandler movie yeah
produced by uh you know spring hill and
braun all those guys and adam sandler
and he i just feel like he's one of
those guys that is just he could be a
professional hobbyist like he could play
you know bowling or darts or golf and
it'd be exciting and be exciting it'd be
great um you know caddy came out won the
three-point competition as a
seven-footer as a center um you're like
yeah yeah big big fella i told him that
when i saw him i was like hey man
you torched these nets you got chill
tonight and of course he's a big three
to to put them up and they won that game
but
uh d-lo that whole team like i was happy
for him yeah i still have a lot of great
relationships there like we saw uh you
know greg farnham who was
um the head atc there had athletic
trainer and i still have a great
relationship with and people that you
know i still
go to dinner with or see when i'm there
so in a lot of ways it was very great i
don't wish away any of my time there i
learned a lot both good and bad but you
know i'm
sitting here now for for a reason put
the time in and
again a lot of ugliness and a lot of
situations but i think looking back i i
choose to see you know the relationships
i made and yeah again the good and the
bad that got me here totally i mean you
mentioned your mental health in
minnesota it is mental health awareness
month
um and
you obviously have been such an advocate
and an important person in terms of
pushing that conversation forward
especially in the mba
but it's interesting you say that
because something i've always wondered
is so you know now we know you as
somebody who is vocal about it who
doesn't mind discussing it who is able
to
feel the things that he feels in the
open
but what was it like for you when nobody
knew like what were those times like
in medicine nobody knew yeah when nobody
knew uh very lonely and i think that
that's a component of
um mental health that's that's
overlooked whether it's loneliness in in
your struggle or loneliness uh
just straight across the board i think
you know it's funny i was on a uh
chicago all-star i'd flown there and i'd
done a panel with michael wilbon um
giannis
chris paul
and president obama
and i had kept talking about we had
mental health was one of a big part of
the discussion and we were all talking
about
uh between the
three players up there that you know
kind of how we're helping the
communities you know what do we see
moving forward um and so my
thing was mental health and
president obama was like you should also
think about this in terms of loneliness
you know what we've seen
from that perspective and i'm like
we need to talk about this again so we
went back and
you know behind the curtain when we were
all done i just picked his brain
on that and that is such a major
component you don't understand
and i did a video on it on my instagram
during the pandemic the negative effects
like
heart disease how it can affect your
brain
and just long-term effects of you know
there's like long-term effects of poor
sleep like it's very similar with
loneliness and it's like
you know it's certain people it's like a
you know broken heart it's almost like
when an elderly person loses that person
that they love in their life or that
thing that they love yeah
um
it's a lot it's a lot and i feel like
that
speeds up the process of them slowly
you know getting to the other side i
truly feel that and for sure i think
that
relationship with yourself or with
others is the thing that you probably
you know people think i want more money
i want more fame i want more of this but
at the end of the day i think it's the
ability to do this
and the relationships that you have
totally within your life so i think
and it's time like it's elastic you can
always um you know make more money
you can always get more instagram
followers or be more popular whatever it
may be but i think
you know you can't stretch time we only
have a certain amount here so love up
the people that you know are in your
life
so
and i
want to try and get this thought out
correctly
the thing that sticks out to me
whenever somebody
makes the amazing decision to talk about
their mental health
is you would think in some ways it would
have like an adverse reaction like now
i'm telling you guys how i feel right
that is going to lend to like more
anxiety yeah or like more nervousness
does that make sense
i thought at first it very well might
yeah but again like
i know uh demar went on your show and we
had texted um
before he did that and like he's and i
always say this like he's
he's the guy like he was the one who was
like you know what
you know you know it's it it's it can
get really dark and you know the
depression is is something that's heavy
and he's continued to to speak about it
like i'm so happy for him
that he had such a unbelievable year
this year
like i really am and every time i see
him i'm like i don't think he like truly
gets it
but like i love that dude i love what
he's about i love his story as well like
with his father and how proud his mom
is of him um like this year him finding
his joy back like that makes me happy
for him because
of what he did for others but like
selfishly what he did for me yeah um so
again i think
all
skin colors shapes and sizes
um
you know sexual preference profile
socioeconomic status like just all the
things across the board everybody
deals with stuff everybody's going to go
about it
at their own pace but i think the on the
other side of
sharing that i mean yeah i did have so
much anxiety what's it going to be like
when i press send on this article and
you know what are people going to think
of me am i going to be looked at as
you know weak or is it going to affect
my livelihood is this going to shorten
my time in the nba and then like where
is my identity after basketball but
thankfully it was mostly i mean it was
accepted and well received and you know
from there like demar and i've got to
work together on on several things
mental health related and i would hope
helped a lot of people
there's licensed mental health
professionals that we did a great job of
using this year as a cavs team but on
every single team
they're continuing to make the next step
the nba as the pa is as well and just
not only you know always talk about
resources but um
you know it's not only just the player
but it's his whole family yeah because
think about like it's a you know we're
this whole league is is
built on the shoulders and and the
giants of of you know the black
community and like think of
you know i talk about damar it's like
it's just you know he had to feel some
sort of way because we had talked about
like one more thing that that you know
america or
you know that level of business uh can
use against him and he's still and his
basketball and he's a man like all these
things a lot of intersectionality
happening yeah so a ton of intersection
and i was like
he is
more than just a i mean a superstar
athlete like as a human being for him to
do that um i didn't even i don't even
know if he knew that the impact he was
going to have on people but
um
i mean it's just a amazing to see you
know the the dak prescott's the naomi
osakas the simone biles
the people own up to it and
be like
you can't use me against me i always say
it's funny like of course like you know
white rapper eminem blah blah blah uh
but
eight mile like at the end when he's
like you know i do live in a trailer
with my mom about all this stuff and
like says all this [ __ ] i'm like okay
kind of a weird
you know three minute freestyle whatever
it was
pop a dot got him off uh but but he was
owning him he owned the whole thing and
then he had nothing to say
so like i always think it's funny it's
like you know own it so you can disown
it like you can't use me against me yeah
you know so the thing i think that stuck
out for a lot of people you talk about
owning the things that have happened to
you is in the article when you talk
about the panic attack right
have you had panic attacks since
very my
since i've
i got my medication right which i have a
i have a funny relationship with because
my hope is that you know people wouldn't
have to medicate and
use
ssris as much as they do and i think you
know the the
you know where
all of this is going is you know like
psychedelics and and guided um
you know trips with a doctor who can put
you through it um is incredibly healthy
and a lot of my friends that have either
done ayahuasca or have done ketamine or
have done psilocybin or mdma or you know
the whatever the toad compound is i
forget like
have gone through it and out the other
side they're like man i've like waned
off
some of my meds i don't have to take it
as much like my brain chemistry feels
really good i'm very happy
so i think once i got
myself once i got my meds right and was
really proactively you know doing my
therapy and
owning
who i am and you know trying to stay
present and trying to have balance like
those are the two of the hardest things
i feel like in life is like all right
balance like i'm
overextending myself or i'm not doing
enough like where's the middle ground in
that
staying present i think we're always
looking at what's the next thing like
who's your next interview or what's it
you know what
there's like this destination addiction
like yeah that's the neck yeah and i i i
do think there's a lot of happiness in
having something to look forward to 30th
birthday um
yeah so
but then like looking back and it's like
you you want to go to sleep and maybe
this is why i had trouble sleeping
more than or less than i used to now but
it's because i would be like all right
time to go to sleep and what happens you
think of the worst things that happened
to you in the last 10 years yeah no
totally yeah like oh man failure oh man
what an embarrassing moment or you know
just
just stuff like that so i think um
but so how did just to clarify yeah
because i know what you're saying but
so have you have you had i'm sorry so
not to that extent because that was so
public i think when i was younger
when those
things would happen i always said like i
had a waste place to escape
and just
like collect myself and it was in
when it wasn't and i was like at home or
if i
you know i
felt like i needed a mental health day
and i had to go to school like it was
more like
rage fits like yeah they were just like
you know throwing yourself into a pillow
and and felt that way and never
i was more destructive i would never
take it out on another human being it
was more just like destructive within my
own space
yeah like shaq always talks about like
tearing up the locker room he's like man
if i had eight points at halftime i
would have torn up the locker room it's
like that was me like in my room because
i had no way to no tools to express
myself i didn't have the presence of
mind to like
deal with this like pit of my stomach
feeling that i still have to this day
but again it's like changing your
relationship with it
that
i just had
like so much angst and anxiety and i
didn't know how to or why i felt that
way and on the other side of that there
were times where i just like couldn't
get out of bed
um so yeah i mean i think
definitely to a lesser extent i'm still
not
as comfortable in public as i would like
to be
i don't know if it's like agoraphobia
like fear of public embarrassment but
it's not like it's more
you know if people like have your
cameras on you or like the world starts
closing in on you like i say i feel like
i'm in a permanent elevator sometimes
you know like i'm in just like this
permanent closed space and um
it's like i'm
you know people laugh like channing will
laugh he's listening it's like i sweat
and
you know it feels like in your brain
when you're like okay i'm starting to
sweat you start to sweat more yeah and
then like you're like oh man i'm having
anxiety more anxiety more yeah and then
like oh man here comes three more people
like coming they're coming up to me and
like okay there's gonna be more so like
you have this
um
really vicious cycle um
that can be ugly and i think that can
put you into panic but i've been able to
to
you know keep that at bay i always think
about like
you know when i'm when i'm you know
having a couple glasses of wine like
that's kind of how i'm buzzing and how
i'm feeling uh at most points now just
because i feel like i've done the work
i'm in a good place but i have to be i'm
a lot more proactive than i used to be
yeah so i think that i've been able to
keep those
um at a place where i'm not ending up on
the floor of a locker room and and you
know having to be oxygen and go to the
hospital yeah you know i mean you talk
about being proactive now and knowing
how to deal with it but i've heard you
say you know before
you learned you would self-medicate
yeah how did you self-medicate alcohol
a lot of alcohol
what is a lot of alcohol um
yeah again
nights you don't remember so you can
forget i guess and um
people
sometimes i guess find solace or
or think they do as what i should say uh
in the bottle in a bottle
um
and i knew it wasn't healthy but i just
i didn't care i think i wanted to
you know
dull the pain make it seem put it over
there somewhere if i could and
again a lot of people don't i just i
just
was minnesota that was cold i was inside
like that's when i i talked about in my
in my other article i wrote that i would
just keep
yeah putting it away yeah oh you guys oh
you guys are going out okay perfect
that's even better yeah okay you're good
you know so i had to like really drink
in order to meet them out then i just
drink more and it was a it was an ugly
cycle it was a
yeah never-ending
um
ugly thought process and again that i i
don't feel like that helps yeah
absolutely and this was like in season
this is when you were yeah and that was
before i started drinking tequila and
understanding that everything else is a
suppressant
you know like you know wine and tequila
i stay in my lane now so i know i know
better to uh you know not
overdo it um
but again balance yeah i know last
season you know it was a difficult one
for you because i believe what you got
injured in preseason and so then you
missed the regular season opener and
then you came back and you re-aggravated
it yeah so then
i
got contact trace
when i was still rehabbing so i had to
stay uh no i i was able to fly back to
to cleveland even when i was contact
trace but i couldn't come into the
facility for i think over a week yeah
and
you know i'm trying to keep myself in
shape um at home but there's nothing
like actually playing right but i'm like
i don't care i'll even if i need to play
20 minutes tonight i will
and so i'm still dealing with you know
this little micro injury um you know my
right calf thought i could get over it
in the time that i was out there our
first game was
in detroit and then we played it back to
back against philly
and
if my recall serves me right i think we
went into overtime or double overtime in
that first game and um you know we tried
to put me at a
minute restriction the first game i said
i'm fine we got to win this game we did
i played 38 minutes the first night and
i'm like i'm playing tomorrow i don't
care i'm playing every game that i can
and um it's like my goal of of being
available and
the next night it was like the the first
quarter i think i'd gone up for like a
hook shot against
um
embiid or simmons or somebody and as
soon as i went up i just felt my calf
yeah i was like that's it like i'm gonna
be out for a little while and the reason
i ask that is because i know something
you've also said is basketball in many
ways has served as like a safe space for
you it's like an escape for you totally
so in that period do you find yourself
drifting
not as much anymore because i have so
much to um
first of all i have a dog no i
have a dog
but i was able to
be in a space like it feels i'm just
like a giver at heart too but i also
like to work on things whether it be
you know business or or you know books
or film or just like that can also just
be hobbies too like um i think when
there's like this negative space
in life or there's too much time and and
i always
you know there's this great quote i try
and live by shakespeare of course but as
things one are done joy's soul lies in
the doing like i set out to do whatever
it may be like i want to fill my time
with stuff that might you know i always
use curiosity as a weapon
um because i am just generally curious
but i think that allowed me
when i had basketball taken away from me
and it used to be just like that's my
identity that's my happy place that's
where i can go to like find that inner
peace and happiness you know i have
a number of things outside of that um
that
now basketball that i can work on and
and be happy in doing that so i think
you know whether it be
you know two years three years five
years whatever it may be like when i
hang it up and
uh throw the shoes over the telephone
wire like i'll have i'll transition into
um
whatever it may be and be in a play
obviously having the game taken away
from you you feel something yeah like
i've had to talk to jj about that like
how does it feel yeah but i still think
uh you know i'll be in a better place
than i would have had i not
you know
done this work on myself and and
um have learned from a lot of those
people before me all right i love it
well i have one more phrase before we
turn it over to the fans that have been
that have been
questions for you
[Laughter]
um
so one of your passions obviously is
wine as we've talked about and i know
you also will keep corks
tell me the best conversation you've had
over a bottle of wine that no one knows
about
man last night i felt like i had a great
conversation
i met a buddy of mine michael who lives
in france
who's setting up some of the winery
visits that we're going to
and a couple weeks uh in burgundy
and he's such a fascinating man like he
was the head of warner music for uh
warner brothers music for uh all of
france um he worked in the music
industry
um
he worked he's like he worked so many
interesting and cool jobs and then ended
up
in you know the wine world and working
directly with the the chateaus and but
that again it's just my curiosity like
that's
as of late i mean there's been so many
great conversations over wine and i
think that's the beauty of it that's why
i think like you know plug here but with
chosen family like that's our ideas
shout out to channing
chase everybody chose the family but
that's kind of our concept is like
there's so much
beauty in the in between and wine is
this connector of people and
i think it's you know a beautiful thing
like we're you know a black-owned
business and we're we're bringing more
people into the space also shout out
carlton what's up um but i think that's
the beauty of talking to michael last
night like all these people that he's
talking about and met and
um you know worked with uh just it's so
beautiful that it just brings everybody
together all over the world and every
wine bottle tells a story totally so
like i don't have a definitive answer of
now if we're talking about like best
balls of wine that's a different story
but like best
wine conversation and conversation over
wine or like you know
i think there's
there's too many to count i mean it's
just been it's been such a big part of
my life the past 10 or so years no i
love it okay yeah you're so like
pacific northwest totally totally that's
why i went with the green today how
close were you to going to north
carolina
close i loved it like how like how close
um
yeah maybe close is a strong term but
like i
my dad's assistant high school coach was
jim harrick who
you know coached the abandoned brothers
tyler sydney so we always we always grew
up going to oregon games and we always
grew up going to ucla games especially
they won the national championship in
95.
um so ucla was like always in the back
of my mind yeah my dad was funny like
that like you know you hold on to
certain things and my dad
when i was we were playing in the bob
gibbons um
tournament invitational whatever it was
at north carolina and and duke and you
know everywhere and you know that space
i think some games were at wake forest
nc state like the whole deal and
um my dad gave me a book it's like
it's a little blue book and it's uh
coach wooden's and we're traveling from
portland all the way to north carolina
like portland's or excuse me john
wooden's like lifetime
observations and quotes and all this
stuff so i was just reading it on the
book and i i just fell in love with the
legacy of ucla
again so i kind of i kind of knew and he
was nudging me in that direction but
plus all my
my family besides my immediate family is
in southern california um so i had the
roots down there we had the
relationships and also
they had been to two straight final
fours like that was badass yeah so i'm
like
um
you know i have relationships there that
you know will be forever so i was i i
love north carolina one of the biggest
regrets um
in my life is
not because it all happened so fast um
but it could have just been a couple
minute conversations was not having
um before i made the decision that the
conversation with roy williams about um
i was choosing ucla because it was
literally we went to
i was like all right i'm ready to do
this ready to uh commit all right we got
to set up
the press conference straight to it did
it and then i'm like
uh so what do i do now you mean like not
giving the respect of the call like that
i'm going to choose and he deserved it
yeah yeah and i think that's in in life
and in relationships that's probably one
of my my biggest regrets is is
i don't know if it was presence of mine
i don't know if it was the anxiety of
being a teenager or
you know just but like paying your
respect to to a you know a great coach
and a and a person who's done right by
so many players that i have played with
and come before like roy
roy did his thing he's one of the
greatest college coaches of all time and
somebody that you know a lot of people
admire so i i wish i could have that
moment
did you tell him sorry for not calling
no
no well roy kevin is sorry for not
calling
man a man yeah that's that's something
he's at home by his phone yeah he's just
chill he's waiting he's right he's still
same number same man
we also have to do a top five segment as
you do in every episode let's do it i
thought that for you since you had you
know this great kind of like redemption
season come back season whatever coming
back from your injury i want your top
five player comeback seasons just your
favorites
ooh
um has to be basketball
i don't know what do you say uh it can
really be whatever you want top five
like come back let's do basketball
all right can i say like mj coming off
of like wearing the totally maybe even
the next year because you know they lost
to orlando horace grant was like hoisted
on the shoulders and then they went and
got smacked
um in the finals but yeah mj um
paul george when he came off of his
injury i was i was actually i remember
we were i was on the flight like flying
into vegas to to see some friends but
also to to watch that game or catch the
second half i forget but i remember
right when i landed it happened earlier
right when i landed
my phone just blew up and i felt so bad
for him
um but he came back and he came back you
know stronger he's really you know come
back to
you know prove himself at every every
level people talked about him in the
playoffs then he went you know did his
thing so pg
mj
um
you know the big one there's a big one
chicago bull
oh d-rose yeah 100
somebody that i grew up with love still
to this day
um
yeah d rose 100
myself no um you can put yourself in
there well just because i'm not gonna be
able to fill up the top five all right
caleb yeah uh me as a uh yeah i'll be
this uh i'll be the sixth the sixth man
on the six people um
shoot i know that's so hard on the top
have it that means i know but like annie
had a comeback shanny had a nice little
channing by the way respect yeah he had
a lot of talks about that like speaking
of game taken away from you and doctors
telling you you might never play again
or won't play again yeah he's like no no
i got this yeah came back and um
i mean think about after the fact what
he did like again like even
just
a
collision course being such close
friends um won a championship in 16.
absolutely so you want to put channing
in there 100 so we have mj
paul george derrick rose channing and
you can always be fine all right just
for the sake of time i'll say myself
yeah
just for the sake of time caleb i love
it solid solid top five yeah there we go
i like that thanks for the help with d
rose that's a hundred percent it might
even be yeah the number yeah yeah
because you know then they're gonna say
didn't say derrick rose but i got you
back yeah i'll get you back
um what are the people saying rocky
all right a lot of uh cleveland fans
saying thank you and that they love them
i love them
i love them um okay hi kevin are you
looking to finish your career in
cleveland would love to do that
i'd love to do that the question was are
you looking to finish your career in
cleveland oh i'm sorry that's okay state
the quest they teach you that in media
training when you're
19 years old coming into the league
yes um am i looking to finish my career
in cleveland i would love to do that um
i would love
to have my jersey hanging up in the
rafters i know that's not my decision
but um
cleveland's been really good to me
ohio's been really good to me the people
have been really good to me um i love
this team that we have i mean they're
really fun
every day we show up to work and go to
work and have fun doing it so i mean
again i think all of those things adding
up
that accumulation is is
great i mean it puts a smile on my face
just trying to think of the word oh i
love that now i mean i know you've said
that it'd be a storybook ending if
lebron finished in cleveland
it's just me and you you can tell him no
it is have you yeah he told me he's
coming back it's a sure thing
um and then he's going to figure out
like brony and
no um i don't know if if
i feel like it would even be cool if you
know just it's like one of those things
where it's like a
a one game
yeah just to say like oh you know people
ask where'd you finish your career like
i finished in cleveland yeah no matter
if you checked in or whatever like
obviously i know he wants to have a like
a kobe type exit where he scores 60 and
does his thing which like
he probably will where it will be who
the hell knows but at the end of the day
i think retiring at cav
for him um the city
and
akron and ohio they just i mean he's
i'll have that statue i can't wait till
that goes up i'll be there totally love
it another one speaking of statues a lot
of people think that you deserve a
statue
no i no
maybe a
paperweight
why do you say no to the statue because
i think i think that like okay the
baseball hall of fame is like
so hard to get into right it is and
i think the basketball hall of fame less
so even though it's an unbelievably
esteemed thing and
i hope that one day i'll be there but
statues
like how many are there 15 maybe
maybe that is the true greatness statues
if you have a statue and there's going
to be a lot of guys from this generation
that are going to get them
and i mean like lebron's going to get
one steph will get one
um i'm going to forget a ton of guys but
like
you just saw dirk get one
um does tim duncan have one yet i don't
believe tim house but i might be wrong
because he should yeah for sure he is a
guy that is worthy of 100 i think kg
but that's tough like where does he get
one right like he got his number retired
in in boston but
you know he was mvp and yeah so it's
it's tough but i think
no i do not deserve a statue
but
they
i think that is the
highest
level of honor and respect
uh because i think that's like true
truly being immortalized yeah i mean
okay this is obviously way too early
prediction time
but of these like young players
tell me the two that you think are most
likely to eventually have like a
statue oh
um
there's some talent there's talent those
20-somethings those 20-something i'm
trying to i'm trying to if somebody did
like a top
whatever 20 or 15 or 10 under 25 i'm
trying i mean there's so luca jason john
donovan trey but i think luca
um
[Music]
yeah
jaw
you can only pick two
i know it's hard
like there's half a dozen or so i could
say okay they they could really
they could really do it um
you know it's gonna be depend on of you
know like championships and i'll start
get like you know withstanding the test
of time
body holds up numbers like there's a lot
of factors into it um
you know even with like manu it was fiba
basketball the fact that they um won the
2004 olympics was like you know that
solidified him in in defeat because it's
accumulation
but then statue wise like that is
a whole different ball game so
there's a few
there's a few um
but you know i'm like waiting for you to
tell me too
i'm i'm i'm safe in saying those two but
i'm also safe and saying i don't know
but you're like there's so many
opportunities yeah no idea yeah i think
that there's
yeah
we have yet to see how good some of them
can be but there's definitely this the
the game i'll say this is in very good
hands and you guys know who you are yeah
and i also think like your answer like
it's not even about like talent like
you're saying oh i prefer luke and john
i think there is something to
players being synonymous with their city
like that's what gets you the statue and
it's like
jaw kind of like is memphis like luca
will probably be in dallas forever you
know so it's it's really about trey is
like very atlanta atlanta like you have
and honestly
i have said this to form people like
what trey has the opportunity to become
like the greatest hawk of all time 100
percent like it's not like there's
obviously we have dominique wilkins and
stuff but there's not like this litany
of players
that you are having to overcome oh he's
going to be right there yeah yeah 100
yeah okay jinx yummy
all right uh rocky
[Laughter]
it makes me have any individual goals as
you near
the later end of your career they wanted
to save it yeah um
honestly goals would just be
again i think
it's funny like
speaking i know we spoke about usa
basketball earlier but you know someone
i forgot to mention was
uh the former commander chief of the
armed forces general dempsey uh him and
his wife deeney like he they told me
like
in the military
you know being available for that next
man or that next person like being
available like i just like glued myself
to that idea um and i i really wanted to
you know obviously covet happened so um
those were games that i missed but
outside of that no no in no injury
related games uh
were missed and i think
honestly
if i feel good i'm healthy and i'm in
shape which is
mostly under my control then i can be
available and if i'm available and
feeling good i'm gonna play good and i
just i understand and know myself in
that way so yeah just be available and
then
i think with that it just kind of allows
you to to lose yourself in the game and
play free
i think you've like set the record for
like trade rumors
yeah minus this year yeah now they're
like we can't get rid of them
and i mean like in a good way not a
negative connotation yeah yeah
definitely since i yeah since i've been
there oh no it's always like how quickly
can we get rid of this guy
who's the lowest common denominator oh
it's kevin let's let's let's send him
out of here oh my gosh any more rocky
no no
i knew you were gonna i do not and like
you know
i'll say it about today it's like you
know again lowest common denominator
like are they gonna go after james are
they gonna go after doc like
i just like doc as a human being so
i know that he put in the time and who
knows is he the best fit is the best you
know coach for that team i don't know
but
you know it's like
either the disrespect from players the
disrespect from the media like
again
you know words are win right like that
just kind of like
goes past he's like just write it
whatever you gonna write just write it
like you saw that today but
um i think that they're you know a lot
of the time i'm talking about like
meeting people halfway with respect i
just don't think it's there with coaches
um and it's so much you know this league
and life in general is like what have
you done for me lately and i get that
you have to produce and you know we
that's what he and the collective we as
players get paid for it you have to
produce you have to you have to show
something um
but i think he said it perfectly today
like every season you go in thinking
like we're going to win a championship
and and this team had a real shot and we
didn't do that you know do i deserve to
be fired that's not my decision yeah but
i think
being a coach is is hard i've you know i
haven't always been the easiest player
to coach um
why not no i just mean like i was young
or i was i was feeling some sort of way
one game or two games or you submit like
just [ __ ] like that um that a coach just
kind of absorbs is like it's part of the
part of the job
um and i'd like to think i've i know
that i've had far more great moments or
good moments than you know moments i
wish i could take back but
um as a coach i just think
i would love to do i would do player
development i would do you know stuff
like that where i could really help a
player come into his own and take the
next step but
um
like a head coach
ah
i just couldn't see myself doing that
yeah that's fair but of course i say it
now and who knows yeah
i'm wearing last one
do you think the cavs will make a
playoff run next year and if not what's
the one thing
do you think the cavs will make a
playoff run yes it's not what's the
thing that would prevent no i think we
will and the only thing that can prevent
it is
um
health we fought a battle of attrition
this year and and
had so many games missed due to injury i
mean lowry was out from rolling his
ankle karis uh rolled his ankle um right
when we got back from all-star break j.a
broke his finger evan was in and out dg
was in and out with his back
um
you know dean wade meniscus like we had
guys you know even you know like lamar
miss gang like everybody you know
outside of myself i think thankfully um
you know i didn't miss any games but um
i was fortunate
but those guys that's the only thing
that's gonna hold us back i think that
we have a
a great shot to
even make the next step
uh coming off this summer and we'll be
hungry not only to to make the playoffs
but um
you know give ourselves a real chance to
uh to win and move on absolutely i mean
i i don't mean to end on a low note but
with it being mental health awareness
month i think it's important um because
i know something you really want to do
is make sure you speak to the youth and
the kids that are dealing with some of
the similar things that you have
we lose so many people to suicide and i
know suicide is a thing that you thought
about the thing that you contemplated
and i think an important thing is
knowing that there is hope and that it
does get better
why didn't you do it
um i think because at the time like i
talked about like a playbook it just
wasn't um
having transparency or being vulnerable
um was looked at
um
i should say transparency in your
struggle
uh was looked at as weak and
you know i had to be the number one
player in the country and the and the
guy that everybody looked to and could
um
you know go out there and
produce and lean on and trust and i felt
like all that would be taken away if if
that was the case but for me
people ask me all the time like what
would you tell your younger self and it
goes back to that idea of like nothing
haunts us like the things we don't say i
would have said speak your truth because
i i i just imagine
all those in between and great moments
in life and even some of the the moments
that are tough um and teach perspective
would have just been
that much better and maybe i could have
even impacted my life in other people's
lives
more so had i done that totally
earlier but also i would hope that um
you know young men or women at
that age because there's been so much
that's even come out this this past
probably past three or four weeks like
one in five high school students
since the pandemic have um
thought about seriously taking their
lives like you're on a high school team
and one of the guys on the starting five
or girls on starting five has considered
that
suicidal ideation and
really
you know planned follow-up and and
thought about killing themselves so i
think it's a it's a really important and
meaningful and
moving conversation to have and i think
that that's
you know there's
the thought is you know to be a part of
something bigger than yourself and and
very
you know you mentioned the word hope i
think that's that's kind of what we're
getting at is establishing hope for for
younger people in the next generation
but also those that are going through it
at any age or wherever they are in life
absolutely well i i think you know this
but you genuinely are so important i
think to everyone in the landscape it's
not just about like you being an nba
player that's talking about it's just
you being a person that's talking about
it so you demar dac all the people you
taste for sure absolutely more the
better yeah well thank you everyone's
welcome and for like actually coming on
oh i'm here two years later
yeah i didn't know if we were gonna like
you know a
year or two years ago if we were even
able to do this so this is great totally
thank you for having me absolutely